[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN AGUINIS: So
I'm standing here
with Eric Seidel, who is one
of the founders of Flutter.
And I believe it was
called Sky back then
when you first started it.
And you were actually
on the Chrome team
when this idea came to be.
But you've seen it go
from an idea to now
a globally used framework.
So I'm curious just what
was your initial vision
with Flutter, and how has
that changed, if anything,
and evolved?
ERIC SEIDEL: Yeah,
Flutter started out
with a very different
purpose than it has now.
Flutter started out as just
trying to make the web better.
We were trying to
make Chrome better,
trying to make Chrome smaller.
And when we first
started Flutter,
we took a couple weeks, and
we took a razor to Chrome,
we said.
We even called the test results
that we came up with Razor.
And we cut down Chrome and just
tried to make it fast and small
and remove some
of the sharp edges
that the web has developed
over the many, many years.
Anyway, so we ended
up with a faster web,
but that wasn't sufficient.
We wanted to do more.
And we ended up adding
more and more and more.
And once you add things,
you're no longer in the web.
And we rewrote the whole
system maybe three times since,
but what we have now is Flutter.
MARTIN AGUINIS: That's great.
So what we have
now, obviously, has
been used all over the world.
But I'm curious along
that adoption journey,
was there a moment where you
went, wow, this is legitimate,
this is really taking off?
ERIC SEIDEL: I think
the biggest moment
for me was Hamilton, when
we saw the Hamilton app
ship, when we saw that team
be successful with Flutter.
We'd seen teams be
successful inside Google
for several years.
But seeing folks that
we had much less ability
to talk to on a
minute to minute basis
be successful with
this technology,
helped me believe that,
yeah, anybody can use this.
MARTIN AGUINIS: That was great.
I know now they have
over a million installs,
and a lot of people
are winning tickets
through that app or $10 tickets.
So that's really great.
So where do you see Flutter
headed in the future?
ERIC SEIDEL: So
one of the things
that we're seeing
with Flutter is
we're seeing people take
Flutter to more places.
We started with
I was in Android,
because that's where so
many developers are today.
But we've seen people
bring Flutter to desktop.
We've seen people
experiment with Flutter
on all sorts of different
sizes and shapes of devices.
And I'm really excited to
get to light up more devs
as that continues.
MARTIN AGUINIS: Awesome.
Thank you so much, Eric.
[MUSIC PLAYING]